Hallo Guten Tag, David ist mein Name, ich bin der zuständige Arzt für Sie.
Ich würde gerne mit Ihnen das Aufnahmegespräch führen.
Bevor ich das mache, muss ich um Ihre persönliche Information bieten.
Sind Sie damit verstanden?
Ja Doktor, natürlich, natürlich. Bitte, bitte.
Ich habe ein Problem mit Doktor.
Ich wollte jetzt eigentlich nach Istanbul fliegen, aber ich kriege keine Luft.
Ja, wie heißen Sie?
Mein Name ist Franziska Müller.
Könnten Sie bitte Ihre Vor- und Nachname bestabilen?
Nein, Franziska, Friedrich, Richard, Anton, Nordhol, Zeppelin, Ida, Siegfried, Karl, Anton.
Franziska, der Nachname ist Müller.
Ja, und Nachname Müller.
Müller, ja.
Okay, feste.
Und wer alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 55 Jahre alt.
Ja, wie groß sind Sie?
Bitte.
Wie groß sind Sie?
Warum ist das wichtig, Herr Doktor?
Ich bekomme keine Luft, ich habe mir so eng.
Mein Flugzeug fliegt gleich weg, Herr Doktor.
Schauen Sie bitte nach, ich möchte mein Flugzeug nicht verpassen.
Ja, ich muss diese Gespräche unterbrechen.
Das ist ein Notfall sein.
Das könnte ein Notfall sein.
Und ich schreibe ein EKG und ich messe Ihre Vitalparameter.
Dann können wir weiter machen.
Wieso machen Sie ein EKG?
Glauben Sie, es ist ein Herzproblem?
Ich habe nur Luftlund.
Ja, es könnte sein.
Machen Sie mir keine Angst, Herr Doktor.
Dann bitte beilen Sie sich, mein Flugzeug wartet.
Ja.
Können wir weiter machen?
Ja, okay.
EKG ist ein Sinus-Rhythmus, Frequenz 80, keine Aufwähligkeiten, keine Ischemia.
Okay, wie viel wiegen Sie?
Ich wiege 85 Kilo.
85 Kilo.
Und wie groß sind Sie?
1,70 m.
Und wann würde Sie genau geboren?
23. März, 1975.
Frau Müller, wie kann ich Ihnen helfen?
Was für Sie so uns?
Herr Doktor, ich bin heute das erste Mal,
wollte ich nach Istanbul in den Türkei fliegen.
Jetzt war eine halbe Stunde, habe ich ganz plötzlich
sein Druck auf der Brust.
Das zieht mir bis hier hoch und ich bekomme Schrechtluft.
Und ich habe das Gefühl,
dass mein Herz ganz kräftig pocht oder klopft.
So, das habe ich noch nie gehabt.
Ich denke, das ist die Aufregung oder die Nervosität,
aber es hört mich auf.
Sind die Schmerzen plöstisch oder allmählich aufgetragen?
Nein, das ist ganz plötzlich gekommen.
So etwas habe ich noch nie gehabt.
Ich habe auch ein bisschen schwere Koffer getragen,
aber das habe ich ja abgegeben.
Ja, treten die Schmerzen anfassartig auf
oder sind sie dauerhafter?
Wir sind jetzt dauerhafter, das geht nicht mehr weg.
Das macht mir richtig Angst.
Wie stark sind die Schmerzen auf einer Skala von 0 bis 10,
wobei 0 keine Schmerzen, 10 am starken Schmerzen?
Gut, es hat etwas langsamer oder weniger angefangen.
Diese halbe Stunde ist es mehr geworden.
Ich habe das Gefühl, es wird so eng auf der Brust.
Ich bekomme Schrechtluft.
Okay, machen Sie sich keine Sorge.
Ich verstehe Ihre Angst.
Ja, Doktor, das sagt Sie so einfach.
Ich mache mir Sorge.
Ich habe jetzt ein bisschen Angst.
Könnten Sie bis zur Ende des Gesprächs aushalten?
Ich hoffe, noch geht es, aber ich befürchte,
dass es immer schlimmer wird.
Okay, ich bin auch ein sehr panischer Mensch.
Ich bekomme gleich ein Panik, wenn so etwas ist.
Könnten Sie die Schmerzen beschreiben?
Sind Sie eher dumm, stehend, brennend?
Er ist so dumm, ich würde sagen.
Er ist ein Druckgefühl, enger Gefühle.
Kein Stechen, nein.
Und gab es Auslöser?
Das kann ich nicht sagen, nein.
Nachdem ich von Check-in weggegangen bin,
hat es plötzlich angefangen.
Ich weiß nicht, ob es die Aufregung ist
oder ob es etwas anderes ist.
Gibt es etwas, das die Schmerzen lindert oder verstärkt?
Nein, kann ich nicht sagen.
Also in diese halbe Stunde ist es sogar schlimmer geworden.
Okay, verstehe.
Haben Sie ähnliche Beschwerden gehabt?
Nein, das ist das erste Mal.
Und verschlimmen sich die Schmerzen im Laufe derseits?
Ja, sagt ich doch, Doktor, hören Sie mir nicht zu.
Seit Beginn in dieser halben Stunde ist es schlimmer geworden.
Deswegen bin ich ja bei Ihnen.
Füllen Sie sich biblisch?
Nein.
Wie ist Ihre Partiz?
Ist ja eigentlich ganz gut.
Strahlen die Schmerzen auf?
Ja, so ein bisschen in den Hals und in die Kiefer hier unten.
Alles.
Haben Sie in der letzten Seite ab- oder zugenommen?
Nein, nein, nein.
Leiden Sie unter Übelkeit?
Wo Sie jetzt Übelkeit sagen, also normalerweise habe ich keine Übelkeit,
aber jetzt seit ein paar Minuten merke ich auch eine leichte Übelkeit bei mir.
Haben Sie erbrochen?
Nein, aber so eine Übelkeit.
Schützen Sie nachts?
Nein, nein.
Also ich habe bisher noch nie etwas gehabt, Doktor,
wenn Sie das wissen wollen.
Ich habe keine Erkrankungen, keine Medikamente, keine Allergien, gar nichts.
Ich war kein gesund.
Ich weiß, dass ich manchmal ein bisschen panisch bin,
aber das ist jetzt ein bisschen etwas anderes.
Okay, verstehe.
Und schlafen Sie gut?
Normalerweise ja.
Sie haben erwähnt, dass Sie keine Vorerkrankungen haben?
Nein, nein, nicht da.
Alles gut.
Und keine Allergien?
Nein.
Keine Verträglichkeit?
Keine Unverträglichkeit, meinen Sie?
Verträglichkeit, ja.
Und Sie haben keine Medikamente eingenommen?
Also ich nehme keine regelmäßigen Medikamente ein.
Und haben Sie Probleme mit dem Stuhlgang oder beim Wasserlassen?
Nein, nein, nein.
Meine Nachbarin wollte mir Tabletten für die Reise mitgeben,
weil sie weiß, dass ich sehr ängstlich bin und sehr panisch bin.
Hätte ich sie nur mitgenommen, ich habe sie leider nicht eingepackt.
Wie heißt diese Tablette?
Ich habe sie nicht eingenommen.
Ich habe sie leider zu Hause vergessen.
Die Nachbarn meinte, das ist etwas gegen Angstgefühl,
gegen Panik und gegen Nervosität, aber ich weiß nicht, wie das ist.
Und ist Ihnen Herzrosen, Herzklopfen?
Ja, ich habe schon so ein kräftiges Porchenklopfen.
Das ist sehr unangenehm.
Und manchmal wird das sehr schnell.
Wenn das Herz schneller schlägt, bekomme ich auch immer schlechter Luft.
Okay, verstehe.
Und rauchen Sie?
Nein.
Ich gratuliere Ihnen, dass Sie nicht rauchen.
Ja, dann bin ich auch sehr stolz, das stimmt ja.
Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Nein, eigentlich sehr, sehr selten, also fast nie.
Ich habe sich ein Glück für mich.
Und bitte nehmen Sie es nicht persönlich.
Das ist eine Routinefrage.
Konsumieren Sie Drogen oder gleiche Substanten?
Nein, nein, nein, das habe ich nicht.
Und lassen Sie uns über Ihre Familie sprechen.
Leben Sie Ihre Familie?
Leben Sie ja, leben Ihre Familie noch?
Sie meinen, meine Eltern, oder?
Ja.
Werben Ihre Eltern?
Ja, ja, die sind wohl aufstehen jetzt gut.
Ja, die leben beide auf.
Und haben Sie Geschwister?
Ich habe noch einen Bruder, der ist drei Jahre jünger an sich.
Ja, ist der gesund?
Ja, der hat auch nichts so weit.
Und treiben Sie Sport?
Ja, ich mache regelmäßig Fitness, ich fahre Fahrrad.
Ich schwimme sehr gerne.
Und ich mache Pilates, Yoga, alles, was so Frauen in diesem Alter machen.
Und wie ist Ihre Familie so stanz?
Ich bin feiergatet und wir haben eine Tochter.
Ist Ihnen geschwollenes Ansehbein aufgefallen?
Oder gerötet?
An den Beinen meinst du, ob ich Oedemä habe?
Nein.
Ja.
Nein, bisher pausch ich nichts.
Nichts ist alles ganz gut.
Und Sie haben erwähnt, dass Sie Brüschmerzen haben und enge Gefühle.
Ja.
Pass ich zusammen und Sie haben erst einmal, okay Frau Müller,
das waren meine Fragen.
Ich denke, eine wichtige Information gesammelt.
Haben Sie Husten?
Nein.
Mir ging es ja ganz gut, deswegen gehe ich ja in den Urlaub,
eigentlich habe ich gar nichts gehabt.
Dass es hier so plötzlich kommt, das macht mir Angst.
Was ich vielleicht vergessen habe zu sagen,
ich habe das Gefühl, mein Mund ist ganz trocken und kribbelig.
Und an den Händen und den Fingern merke ich auch manchmal so ein kleines Kribbeln.
Ist Ihnen Taupas Gefühl aufgefallen?
Taupen nicht, aber es ist so komisch.
Ich habe das Gefühl, dass so viele einmal sind an meinen Fingern.
Leiden Sie unter Lehmungen?
Nein, bisher war nichts bekannt.
Atmen Sie schnell?
Sag ich doch die ganze Zeit.
Also jetzt, ich merke nicht, dass ich schnell atme,
aber ich bin halt ziemlich aufgeregt und nervös.
Ich habe auch ein bisschen Patis, aber auch dieses Druckgefühl
und diese Luftmutter, die gehen irgendwie nicht weg.
Und könnten Sie Ihre Kind auf dem Brust legen?
Ja, alles geht. Sie sehen, das klappt ja ganz gut.
Leiden Sie unter Kopfschmerzen?
Nein, ich habe nichts, nichts an Vorgeschichte.
Ist Ihnen Schwinderlich?
Nein.
Und wie viel Kissen benutzen Sie beim Schlafen?
Ich schlafe flach auf dem Bauch und gerne eine Bauchschläfe ein.
Ja, Sie können flach legen.
Was machen Sie beruflich?
Ich bin selbstständig.
Haben Sie Stress beim Arbeiten?
Ja, natürlich immer wieder klar.
Selbstständig hat man immer viel Stress.
Gibt es in der letzten Seite besondere Belastungen in Ihrem Leben?
Was besonders nicht, es ist halt immer, wie es immer ist,
bei der Arbeit sagt man natürlich viel Arbeit,
viel Stress immer wieder mal, aber das ist schon immer so.
Ansonsten, in der Familie ist alles okay.
Frau Müller, nach dem Angaben denke ich am ersten eine Akkut-Corona-Dündur um.
Aber das ist nur ein Verdacht und muss durch weitere Untersuchungen bestätigt werden.
Wegen Ihre Beschwerden müssen Sie bei uns bleiben.
Nein, Herr Doktor, wir sagen jetzt los, ich verpasse meinen Flug.
Ich wollte nach Istanbul jetzt.
Ja, ich verstehe, aber Ihre Priorität sollte Ihre Gesundheit sein.
Das gibt es ja nicht, da geht man einmal nach Istanbul.
Was ist mit meinem ganzen Gepäck?
Ja, ich verstehe, dass Sie in Istanbul gehen.
Das ist nur für noch eine Stunde, glauben Sie, dass man das nicht rausholt?
Nein, ich verstehe, aber Ihre Gesundheit sollte an Erste stehen.
Ja, deswegen bin ich auch da, aber können Sie das nicht ein bisschen beeilen,
dass wir schon mal Ergebnisse haben?
Ja, Ihre Zustand könnte lebensbedrohlich sein.
Warum?
Ja, da müssen Sie bei uns bleiben.
Ich werde körperliche Untersuchungen durchführen,
dann ein EKG machen.
Gleichzeitig ist eine Labo-Untersuchung erforderlich.
Deswegen werde ich Ihnen etwas Blut abnehmen.
Okay, aber dann beeilen Sie sich bitte, ja?
Also ich möchte noch, dass alles gut klappt
und ich weiterhin nach Istanbul gehen kann.
Ja, haben Sie Fragen?
Nein, danke.
Ich hoffe, dass da jetzt nichts Schlimmes rauskommt,
wenn ich nicht da bleiben muss.
Ich hoffe, dass ich nach Istanbul weiterhin pflegen kann.
Ja, ja, ich verstehe, das tut mir leid.
Aber Sie müssen.
Das muss auch mir passieren, meine Güte.
Okay, was kommt jetzt dran?
Nehmen Sie Blutabflachen und Untersuchungen?
Ja, vielen Dank.
Ich habe Kollegen oder Kollegen noch andere Fragen.
Aber diese Situation fast eine Düsseldorf-Falle ist.
Echt?
Ja, man muss eine Reaktion geben.
Deswegen?
Deswegen.
Aber dieser andere Patient,
ein Mann und akut korinär-Sendrom, Diagnose,
aber diese Reaktion ist fast ähnlich.
Okay, danke.
Ich gratuliere Ihnen.
Diese Frage haben wir schon beantwortet.
Eine Operation, keine Vorerkrankung.
Sie haben gesagt, dass Ihre Nachbarn sagt, sie ängstlich sind.
Deswegen hat Ihnen sogar Medikamente gegeben.
Ja.
Und woher weiß er das und was passiert eigentlich früher?
Sie sind ängstlich, aber haben Sie Phobien oder Panikattagen?
Ja, ich habe mir gesagt, ich habe ein bisschen Angst vor den Fliegen.
Deswegen hat sie mir diese Tabletten empfohlen.
Okay, nur vor den Fliegen.
Ja.
Ich habe Ihnen gesagt, 55 Jahre und Gewusstatung,
23. März 1975 sagen.
Da muss man 1970 sagen, oder?
79 und deswegen ist diese Situation sehr wichtig.
Muss man in Seldurfalle richtige Antwort geben und recherchieren.
Ich bin aufgeregt, ich bin nervös.
Ja, ja, recherchieren.
Und deswegen eine gute Falle, ich denke, Herr Hocam.
Eine gute Falle, nicht Falle.
Falle, zu sagt dem ich habe, gute Falle.
Ja, der Doktor hat es nicht gemerkt.
Okay.
Falls keine Fragen haben, können wir...
Sind?
Falls keine Fragen sind?
Können wir Arsatz-Geschichte?
Ja, ich habe das nicht gemerkt.
Ich habe das nicht gemerkt.
Falls keine Fragen sind?
Sind? Können wir Arsatz-Geschichte anfangen, Herr Hocam?
Ich habe das nicht gemerkt.
Nein, kein Problem.
Ich bin immer bereit.
Sehr gut, ein Arzt ist immer bereit.
Ich weiß aus Brüche, Habel.
Ja, du hast schon gefragt.
Ja, respiratorisch.
Fangen wir an.
Nein.
Okay, guten Tag.
Ich bin Neue Assistenz in der Notaufnahme.
Ich möchte Ihnen eine Patientin vorstellen.
Haben Sie seit?
Aber natürlich, ich würde mich doch immer, Herr Kollege.
Bitte schön, was haben Sie?
Ja, die Patientin kommt zu...
Entschuldigung.
Es handelt sich um Franziska Müller.
Ein 55-jähriger Patientin.
Sie sei 85 kg.
Sie wiege 1,70 m.
Und die Patientin kommt zu uns.
Sie sei 85 kg.
Und nicht sie wiege 1,75 m, sondern sie sei 1,75 m groß.
Ja.
Die Patientin kommt zu uns wegen halbischtunden bestehenden,
plössig aufgetretenden, prokredienten, persistierenden Brüschmerzen.
Prokredient und persistierend ist gleich.
Also, entweder prokredient oder persistierend.
Beides zusammen geht.
Ja, die Schmerzen wird im Laufe der Zeit verschlimmert.
Ja, das wird prokredient.
Ja, und was ist persistierend?
Dauerhaft.
Ja, weil es ist noch zu kurz, halbe Stunde.
Ja, okay, bestehend.
Also, deswegen ist es sehr ähnlich prokredient, persistierend.
Also entweder prokredient oder persistierend.
Beides zusammen sagt man nicht.
Ja, okay.
Also, seit einer halben Stunde akut aufgetretende, persistierende
Prokredientenschmerzen oder auch deuch-anhaltende Schmerzen.
Okay, verstehe.
Prokrediente Brüschmerzen, Prokredientenschmerzen, die Hals- und Kiefer ausstrahlen.
Die Innenhalts- und Innenhalts- und Kiefer ausstrahlen.
Zu dem beschreiben die Patienten die Schmerzen als dumpf.
Und die Frage nach Auslöser wurde verneint.
Und die Frage nach Linderungfaktor wurde verneint.
Außer dem berichten die Patienten, keine ähnliche Beschwerden.
Zu haben.
Ja, zu haben.
Und die vegetative Anamnese sei bis auf Öbelkeits,
Bomitus, Unauffällig.
Ja, hat sie Luftnot, hat sie darüber was gesagt?
Oder Herzrasen?
Ja, sie klagen über Luftnot und Herzrasen.
Nervosität.
Sie haben Nervosität.
Ist das bekannt bei ihr?
Ja.
Das heißt, ihr habt schon eine Panikstörung oder Angststörung?
Ja, sie haben Angststörung.
Nehmen Sie dann wegen Medikamente ein?
Armvor-Operationen sei...
Nehmen Sie wegen Medikamente ein.
Nehmen Sie dann etwas?
Sie haben keine Medikamente eingenommen.
Sie haben keine Medikamente, okay.
Und wie äußern sich Ihre Angststörung?
Hat sie dazu etwas gesagt?
Oder haben Sie sie befragt?
Wie sind die Symptome Ihrer Angststörung?
Von der Patientin.
Sie haben gerade gesagt, sie hatten eine bekannte Angststörung.
Ja, sie hat gesagt, ich habe Angststörung.
Ich habe Angststörung.
Worvor ist das etwas Krone?
Wie äußert sich diese Angststörung bei ihr?
Welche Symptome hat sie?
Unter welchen Umständen löst bei ihr die Angst aus?
Okay, da würde ich Sie bitten,
da Sie noch mal eine richtige Anamnese machen.
Ja, ich werde bei der körperlichen Untersuchung fragen.
Dann wäre wichtig, hat Sie jetzt noch weitere Symptome?
Aktuell bei der Aufnahme?
Ja, sie klagen über Krebeln,
aber sie haben keine Taubweißgefühle und Parasit.
Wo ist das Krebeln und die Parasit?
Sie hat keine Parasit, aber sie haben Parasit, Krebeln.
Wo ist das Krebeln und Parasit?
Im Arm.
Im Arm, kompletter Arm?
Nein, Finger.
Wo, rechts, links?
Ich werde bei der körperlichen Untersuchung fragen.
Sie hat gesagt, sie hat beide Finger.
Sie hat gesagt, sie hat beide Hände und Finger.
Sie klagen keine Kopfschmerzen.
Wo hat sie noch Krebeln gehabt?
Im Mund?
Ja, im Mund.
Im Mund hat sie Krebeln gehabt, genau.
Die Patienten leiden keine Vorerkrankungen.
Die Frage nach Kooperationen wurde verneins.
Die Patienten nehmen keine Medikamente ein.
Also keine regelmäßigen Medikamente ein?
Tabakkonsum wurde verneins.
Alkoholkonsum wurde verneins.
Drogenkonsum wurde verneins.
Die Frage nach Familien,
in der Familienanamnese
waren Vater und Mutter gesund.
Sie sind verheiratet.
Sie haben eine Tochter.
Sie sind selbstständig.
Was macht sie?
Sie arbeiten selbstständig.
Was macht sie denn?
Ich habe nicht gefragt.
Es wäre interessant herauszufinden,
ob sie eine Modedesignerin oder eine Friseurin machen.
Sie sind Architektin oder eine Wissenschaftlerin.
Sie sind auch ein Erster.
Sie haben viel Stress bei der Arbeit.
Sie haben meist die Selbstständigen immer.
Sie können sich noch mal fragen.
Sie sehen sich nach.
Sie haben eine Corona-Krise.
Ich möchte noch mal zusammenfassen.
Die Übergabe an den Oberarzt.
Er ist ein Ölmuss.
Ich habe eine Patientin aufgenommen.
Eine 59 jährige Patientin.
Er hat akuten Druckgefühle.
Er hat akute Druckgefühle.
Er ist duktisch trainiert.
leichter Übelkeit, aber zudem ist auch eine Angststörung bekannt in der Vorgeschichte,
wobei sie keine Dauermedikation hat. Aktuell hat sie zudem noch Kribbeln im Mundbereich
und an beiden Fingern, die Schmerzen strahlen von der Brust in den Pals und in den Unterkiefer
aus. Sie wirkt auch im Moment etwas panisch. Sonst in der Vorgeschichte sind keine Vorerkrankungen
bekannt. Es ist ja keine Allergien, keine Medikamente. Familienalarmnese ist unaufwählig. Sie ist verheiratet,
hat eine Tochter, älteren Leben und sind gesund. Vielen Dank. Umgefähr. Weiter machen,
Yvrain. Ja, die Anarmnese deutet auch eine Akut-Corona-Sentrum. Differenzialdiagnostisch
kamen eine Pneumotorax, Lungen-Pumoner-Embulie im Betracht. Kamen, die kommt, kommt eine
Lungen. Die von der Differenzialdiagnostisch kommt, eine, okay, im Betracht, jawohl. Woran denken
Sie noch, was ganz einfach ist? Ja, Sie sind Roten-Felag im Brust-Schmerzen. Was Sie? Sie? Roten-Felag,
Roten-Felag, Brust-Schmerzen, Akut-Corona-Sentrum, Spannung Pneumotorax, Lungen-Embulie und
Zephagus Rüptür und Erika Ditt. Okay, woran denken Sie noch bei der Patientin jetzt?
Weil? Andere Differenzialdiagnose. Ja, weil Sie unter Brust-Schmerzen und
Englisch- Sie leidet an Brust, wenn das ist richtig. Sie haben gesagt, Sie haben ihre
Verdachtdiagnose, Akut-Corona-Sentrum. Okay, das ist richtig. Sie untersuchen die Patientin
darauf, machen eine EKG, nehmen ein Borwetter ab und schauen, ob das ein kardiales Problem ist
oder nicht. Und das ist das wichtigste uns Erste. Das ist okay. Differenzialdiagnosen haben Sie
jetzt einige aufgezählt, aber was ist am wahrscheinlichsten, was diese Patientin aber hat? Sie ist
gesund bisher, macht viel Sport, hat keine Vorerkrankungen, Familie ist gesund, sie ist
gesund, sie hat keine kardiovaskilären Risikofaktoren, aber was hat sie? Sie hat gesagt, sie hat eine
Ausstörung, sie hat Panikstörung. Sie ist jetzt auch aufgeregt. Es gibt eine Ausstrahlung. Sie fliegt
das erste Mal nach Istanbul, ist sehr aufgeregt. Sie hat Kribbeln, Pereoralis-Kribbeln. Sie hat
Kribbeln an den Ränden. Sie ist sehr aufgeregt. Da kommt schlecht Luft, ist panisch, ist unruhig. Also,
ich hätte gesagt, das ist einfach eine Panikstörung, was sie hat. Ja, Panikattack. Natürlich muss man
das Kaviale mit betrachten, mit anschauen und auch ausschließen, ganz klar. Aber eigentlich
hätte ich gesagt, so eine junge Frau ohne Vorerkrankungen, das spricht er für eine Panikattack.
Ja. Also manchmal muss man ganz einfach denken. Söferguss-Ruptur, Lungenembolli,
sie war ja noch nicht im Flugzeug, wenn sie jetzt davor... Ja, ich arbeite, ich arbeite da. Natürlich,
wenn sie schon acht Stunden geflogen ist und Zwischenstopp in Frankfurt macht und weiter
dann nach New York fliegt, dann könnte ich mir vorstellen, okay, eine Frau mit deren Alter,
okay. Und wenn sie Hormon-Tabletten hätte, wenn sie geraucht hätte, wenn sie Medikament hätte, also
die Wahrscheinlichkeiten und das Risiko da wären, dann hätte ich gesagt, ja, man muss
einen Lungenembolli denken. Also man muss ja auch überlegen, was ist wahrscheinlich. Es gibt
ein deutsches Sprichwort, viel ist viel, wenig ist wenig. Deswegen immer eher einfach denken. Natürlich
muss man im Hinterkopf auch überlegen, was kann es sonst sein. Natürlich ganz klar. Aber hier hätte
ich gesagt, das ist eigentlich, an erster Stelle hätte ich jetzt meine Arbeitsdiagnose oder
Verdachtdiagnose als Panikattacke, dann als weitere Differenz der Diagnose Akutes Korrelation
und das andere. Sehr gut. Doktor am Flughafen. Gut. Aber Sie wollten noch etwas sagen, habe ich
Sie unterbrochen? Ja, es erfohren eine körperliche Untersuchung. Die Labo-Untersuchung, die
Labo-Untersuchung umfassen Entzündungsparameter sowie Leber, Nieren, Pankreas, Polistas und Nierenwerte.
Und die Herzwerte natürlich. Ja, eine EKG ist erforderlich, um kardiale
Ursache auszuschließen. Welche kardialen Labo-Werte machen Sie?
Troponin, CKMB, LDH, Myoglobin. Ja, Myoglobin brauchen Sie nicht. Proponin und CK reicht.
Okay, sehr gut. Und eine Röntgen-Gegenebrenn-Pars, werde ich eine Röntgen geplant?
Planen, nicht geplant. Werde ich planen? Planen, ja. Okay, alles klar. Sehr gut, das reicht
erst mal. Wir warten mehr Ergebnisse ab. Sie werden sehen, EKG ist unauffällig, Labo
ist unauffällig. Troponin ist negativ, LDH-Mähre sind negativ. Alles negativ. Sie geben der
Patienten ein bisschen etwas zur Beruhigung. Was geben Sie zur Beruhigung? Welches Medikament?
Ich könnte Sie wiederholen, bitte. Was geben Sie der Patientin zur Beruhigung für einen Medikament?
Ein Benz oder die Erzepin? Ja. Volume, die Erzepam, Loherzepam. Also etwas, was Sie,
Xanax, eine Türkei ist Xanax bekannt. Was ist der Wirkstoff von Xanax?
Ich erinnere mich nicht, Loherzepam. Ist es Loherzepam? Nee, glaube ich nicht. Xanax ist
etwas anderes, glaube ich. Aber Loherzepam ist gut. Deutschland ist die bekannte Marke
Tavor. Tavor, Loherzepam. Und das war auch genau das Medikament, was die Nachbarin
gegeben hat. Alprazolam, okay. Alprazolam. Alprazolam ist auch ein gutes Benz oder
Erzepin. Das beruhigt, dann ist die Patientin. Und in Krankenwagen gibt es die Erzepam,
nur diese. Ja, genau, die Krankenwagen ist natürlich die Erzepam. Sehr gut.